I've been saying on my show for quite
some time now but I think it's really
ramped up since October 7th that the one
group of people that it seems to me
really could switch parties right now
are the disaffected libs the kind of old
me and I think I think you to some
extent um I never live unless I was in
my like young 20s well we'll count that
we'll count that a little bit but for
you as for you as I would consider you
sort of as moderate as possible like
logical and moderate as possible for
someone that can be in politics um but
that leads you to generally I think but
correct me if I'm wrong more so
supporting people that are on the right
now what would you as a New Yorker who
you know you've lived in New York for
many years New York media girl all of
that stuff say to your friends that are
that are left leaning but waking up to
the craziness of the dams but that are
still afraid to ever actually pull the
lever for Republicans that that means
that they're somehow evil and they hate
poor people and they're kind of racist
and all of that crazy nonsense I'm sure
you have some of those people in your
life like what what's the messaging that
Republicans should be doing on
that well what's the messages messaging
Republicans should be doing versus what
my own messaging is is different so I
was liberal when I was very young like
in my 20s you know like you're typical I
wasn't really political but if I had to
like check a box I would say I was more
liberal than conservative and my my
social approach I think was more liberal
you know even into my 30s uh but
fiscally and militarily and in some
other ways I was more I was more
right-leaning mhm um now I took a test
like a year or two years ago one of
those online tests about your positions
and it said I'm I'm a Conservative
Republican I'm like a very conservative
Republican I'm like oh I I am now I
didn't realize but okay you know the the
world has shifted underneath my own feet
and what used to be normal policies are
now considered very conservative
Republicans so that's fine I I'm not a
republican I'm an independent people
call me a rhino I'm like oh it's worse
than that it's not I'm not even right
I'm not even saying it yeah no it's far
worse than you know um but I am more
conservative so whatever that is I don't
try to convince anybody when it comes to
politics I just feel like Life's Too
Short you do you one of my best friends
in this world in 2020 was out there
literally campaigning for Joe Biden like
trying to get people to go to the polls
for Joe Biden we would sit we we' talk
about it a little I'd never tried to
convince her not to do it I didn't think
it was fruitful and when he won we all
had dinner together and I'm remember
saying I'm happy you got what you work
so hard for that's it I was I happy Joe
Biden won no I was not but I'm not in
the business of trying to get voters to
change their hearts and Minds I just
think good sense will eventually do it
so this same woman to take for her for
an example kids in New York City School
Co hit they shut her schools down for
over a year she has the money to send
her kids to private school she was in
public school because she felt like I
grew up in this town and I owe it to my
town you know I owee it to sort of life
she was a lefty you know like Public
Schools is the way to go like I
shouldn't pull them out and put them in
some privilege environment well as a
result what did she get she got her kids
out of school for a year finally went to
an open the schools rally you know what
happened she was called a white
supremacist by a bunch of protesters who
were standing there that's when I saw
the light bulb go on right like wait a
minute what's happening maybe I've made
some bad decisions and then it started a
spiral from there you know like the
getting shamed all the time in the lobby
of her building for not wearing a mask
her kidss not being able to play
basketball unless they were double vaxed
at age 13 you know and and so on and so
forth so I really and by the way she
happens to be Jewish so now I mean she's
in full Maga gear she's a registered
Republican she ran for city council as a
republican she's more right than I am so
like life had a way of transforming her
and I was just kind of over there going
come on in the water's F it's fine but
for people who are not ready to pull the
lever for Republican because of branding
I think we have to seed that the
Republican branding is terrible you
shouldn't want to share a jersey with
them they're ridiculous they have absurd
people like why would you want to um You
Don't Have To You Don't Have To Go full
Republican you know you can you can be
where I am you can be a registered
independent you can just vote like a
like a sane person and be free to call
out the nonsense on both sides so that's
kind of what I would say if I were a
registered Republican maybe I would say
it a little differently but I'd say you
don't have to adopt all of us or all we
stand for you just have to understand
what pulling that lever for the Dems
will get you you know little boys
penises are going to be chopped off
13-year-old girls are going to have
their breasts chopped off we're going to
have millions more illegal immigrants
coming into this country with yeah
diseases with fenel that's going to kill
American kids um with a desire to vote
Democrats so they can get more
entitlements back spending which you and
your children are going to have to spend
pay for environmental policies that want
to take away your gas stove and your gas
fireplace while the people pushing them
or driving huge SUVs and flying private
while their Jets wait for them to load
up their ski gear I mean like it's it
doesn't if you're paying any attention
at all it doesn't take long to see the
nonsense unless you've already been
totally indoctrinated on the far
left